Purity spiral members of political
tribes inevitably begin competing with
their fellows to be the most
ideologically pure the constant
one-upmanship toward moral superiority
causes the whole group to gradually
become more extreme for example maoist
China or Twitter Echo Chambers nice that
you drew the correlation between those
two there
yeah
I think people have this kind of
tendency to turn everything into a
competition
and that goes for Morality also you know
if you have a certain
dominant ideology dominant moral
ideology
that's fashionable again going back to
the thing that we talked about before
then people will start competing they'll
turn into a competition and start
gamifying it essentially the adult turn
it into an opportunity to
um
to sort of gain an advantage a social
advantage
uh and this has been shown throughout
history I mean you know it's not just
Mao is China you can look at any regime
that had strong sort of laws against
certain behaviors or in favor of certain
behaviors and you would see that there
were people always who would compete to
either haul out those behaviors in other
people or if they were bad or engage in
those behaviors if they were good
you know literally any any regime you
name you know you you'll see you can see
examples of it it's it's something
that's sort of fundamental to our
species
um and it's one of the reasons why I
think a lot of
regimes become
uh more extreme over time you know uh a
lot of them like for instance if you
look at if we're going to buy this sort
of uh the example of communism
uh you know Lenin was pretty bad he was
quite bad he wasn't Stalin though you
know Stalin was a completely different
category of sort of authoritarian and it
would have continued as long as Stalin
was there because he got worse and worse
as as he gave more and more power it
wasn't just because he was getting more
power it was because the people around
him were also becoming more extreme if
you ever look at people like laurenti
barrier for instance you know they were
also they became more extreme over time
and
part of it was because I think of the
Purity spiral where people felt that
they had to uh compete to be as much
like Stalin as possible in order to
avoid being purged
um so in this case it was literally life
or death matter but it's not always a
life of death matter sometimes it's just
a case of status which is more the case
on Twitter
did you ever hear Tim Dillon push back
on Joe Rogan's view of La comedy
because this is exactly the same thing
so uh Tim's one of the few guys that can
kind of poke back at Joe because he's
you know similar status and he's he's
doing well in comedy scene and stuff
like that
and Joe was saying about how lovely the
LA comedy scene is you know every time
that he goes through there everything's
just fantastic and everyone treats him
so well and Tim sort of bumped in and
said Joe you do know that you're Joe
Rogan right the the way that people
behave when you step into the room is
not representative of how they behave
typically for other people that there is
a reality Distortion field that occurs
when this happens and because of that
your experience may not be
representative of everybody else's I
can't remember the rule that we went
through but this was one of the previous
episodes that you featured on where uh
as somebody gains power the people
around them are more concerned with
appeasing the person in power than
giving them real information from the
world outside so if you have Purity
syndrome yeah Howard Hughes syndrome
thank you that's it
um so if you combine Howard Hughes
syndrome with the Purity spiral the
Purity spiral is the incentive or the
Purity spiral is like the the drive and
the direction that that's the what's
going on and then the Howard Hughes
syndrome is the fuel that persists and
causes that to keep on going uh one one
question I've got in my mind is what
sort of environment
would
engender a more Purity spiral like
situation what are some of the
predictors of a purity spiral do you
think
so they need to be rewards incentives
basically for that kind of behavior they
need to be rewards for extreme Behavior
so
um you know if you if you look at say
Twitter for instance there are rewards
to acting if you're you know if you're
liking right-wing circles for instance
then there's an incentive to act based
you know and if you're in the left-wing
circles and there's an incentive to act
woke because
other people will see you as a sort of
paragon of what they believe and then
they'll they'll want to retweet you and
you know say oh this person if you're
based for instance people say this
person doesn't give a you know he's
you know God basically he's sticking it
to the lips you know he's triggering the
lips or whatever
um and you know vice versa with the with
the left they'll be like you know this
person is calling it out like calling
out Injustice or whatever blah blah so
there's got to be some sort of
um social reward for uh engaging in more
extreme Behavior than your peers uh
that's the first rule and another thing
is this is probably an even better
incentive would be that um
if if there's a punishment for not
acting more extreme and this is more to
do with the sort of stalinist kind of
element of things so if you look at the
purges for instance in fact there's an
even better example than that um if you
look at there's a very famous video of
Saddam Hussein where he basically is in
a room filled with people and um
he basically says that he's uncovered a
plot this was shortly after he assumed
power it was shortly after he assumed
control in Iraq and the way that he
consolidates power was that he basically
concocted this idea that there was a
conspiracy against him so that he could
you know through text to remove people
that he didn't like and he had a list of
names and he said that these people had
betrayed him and there was a big packed
room filled with people all of the sort
of delegates and diplomats and one by
one he called out the names of the
betrayers and they were LED out of the
room to their deaths they were basically
executed and as soon as people realized
what was happening they began to panic
and they began to copy Saddam Hussein's
actions so there's a point where he um
he he was apparently crying or he was
pretending to cry and he got a
handkerchief and he began to wipe his
eyes and immediately the camera pans to
the the crowd to the audience and you
see many like people just get
handkerchiefs out of their hands and
sort of out of the pockets and they
begin to um wipe their own eyes exactly
how Salim says doing and it's I think
it's a sort of it speaks to sort of this
idea that people were so terrified of
dying that they just the only they
panicked and the only thing that they
knew how to do to prevent from dying is
to be as as much like Saddam as possible
I imagine one other predictor or another
predictor
of the Purity spiral would be an
important in-group out-group uh tribal
Dynamic that's happening because the
whole purpose of having a purity spiral
is to identify others right there is us
and there is not us and if you do not do
the things pray do the shibboleths ETC
that is the us then you're anatas and
it's why intersectionality in particular
is a pretty obvious example of what goes
on with regards to a purity spiral
because in part some of it is based on
fanciful exaggerations and also it's
mostly based on not being another as
opposed to being a something when you
have a poorly defined something the only
way you can identify yourself is is not
being the other and what that means is
in order to keep group cohesion together
you need to constantly shave off people
who are others it's like if your mutual
love of an in-group is not bound
together or for that it's bound together
of the mutual hatred of an out group you
need to permanently find new out group
members in order to say well see we're
not we're not that for instance Douglas
Murray uh gay man but like white and
conservative so he's not really a part
of the LGBT movement anymore you know
like you're just gay it's like um dude
you really need to be like gay and black
with a club foot and a gluten
intolerance like that's really where you
need to be at in order to be a part of
our club
yeah absolutely um it's easier to Rally
around shared hatreds than shared values
and so there are people always looking
to create new things to hate just in
order to keep the group together
um you know share values are are okay
for a while but really what people want
is they want to get together to really
hate somebody you know there's a few
things that bring people together like
hating someone else and I think a lot of
this happens like I mean you see it in
um
when uh there's this thing called rally
around the flag syndrome which is a
concept another one of my mega thread
Concepts where it's this idea that when
uh leaders are unpopular
with the public what they do is they
will start conflicts they'll start
foreign conflicts because this will
bring people together against a mutual
enemy and I mean some people have argued
that that Putin part of part of the
reason that Putin invaded Ukraine was
that he was flagging in popularity and
people were becoming disillusioned with
them and so he needed to have a sort of
external enemy to sort of unite the
people and sort of you know create this
this other that they could sort of level
all their hatred against you see it in
the novel Animal Farm as well where um
the character of uh Napoleon the pig
Napoleon um wants to consolidate his
power by sort of
um essentially exiling snowball who's
his rival and then just sort of blaming
him for literally everything that's
going wrong you know scapegoating and
that's how the sort of Animal Farm gets
Consolidated and how they form their
sort of their their Community by hate
hatred rather than love what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]